[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
avant d'avoir des enfants
j'étais quelqu'un d'hyper calme
je ne savais pas que je serai capable
d'atteindre des degrés d'hystérie
parfois aussi énorme
ça passait c'était complexe mais ça
passait mais quand tu es arrivé le
troisième là j'étais au bout de ma vie
entre le petit dernier qui ne faisait
passer nuit et les deux grands qui eux
dormaient bien et qui arrivait le matin
après dispo direct à se mettre sur le
nez au petit déj franchement j'en étais
arrivé au stade où je me disais mais je
vais en prendre un pour tuer l'autre et
après j'ai dormi
alors oui pas étonnant qu'on voit
fleurir de partout des livres et des
articles sur la communication non
violente
l'éducation bienveillante
l'éducation positive alors oui moi j'ai
lu j'ai lu énormément de choses j'ai
compulsé comme ça pour essayer de
trouver des solutions et alors ce qui
m'a rassuré dans un premier temps c'est
de lire que dans ses livres il s'avaient
l'air de dire que tous les parents
étaient dans le même genre de situation
que moi puisque les mêmes propositions
que ce que moi j'avais comme
problématique à la maison était abordé
avec par contre des solutions très
déconcertantes une manière de faire les
choses mais alors complètement différent
de tout ce que je connaissais et il
paraîtrait que ça marche
j'étais un peu dubitative et donc l'une
ou l'autre fois en désespoir de coach
j'ai essayé un de ces trucs que j'avais
lu dans le bouquin et dit donc ça a
super bien marché alors j'ai essayé deux
trois autres choses pour être bien sûr
puis ensuite je me suis inscrite à un
atelier parent qui a tellement changé de
choses pour moi dans ma relation à moi
avec mes enfants que ça m'a poussé à me
former moi pour transmettre ce que
j'avais reçu et donc pendant plusieurs
années j'ai animé des ateliers parents
des conférences et aujourd'hui un
spectacle autour de cette autre manière
là de communiquer
et parmi toutes ces choses qui ont
transformé ma façon à moi d'être maman
il y en a une que j'aimerais partager
avec vous ce soir on va parler de
méthode éducatives et plus précisément
de ce qu'on appelle la violence
éducative ordinaire la claque la tape la
fessée tirer l'oreille ce registre là
pour tout vous dire avant d'avoir des
enfants je m'étais toujours juré que
jamais jamais je n'utiliserai ça avec
mes enfants à moi parce que mes parents
l'ont utilisé avec moi comme beaucoup
d'autres parents et que je me rappelle
très bien ce que je me disais
adolescente par rapport à ça
ne me quitte pas que vous m'aimez
ne me dites pas que c'est pour mon bien
que vous faites ça
il y a d'autres manières de faire les
choses Moi quand je serai maman jamais
je ferai ça
oui mais ça c'était avant d'avoir des
enfants
parce que quand on a des enfants on
essaie passionnément d'y arriver hein
pas utiliser ces méthodes là on discute
on négocie on Parlement ton supplie on
essaye tous les registres
potentiellement utilisables pour y
arriver on a l'impression que il y a pas
d'impact en face et du coup on se
retrouve à utiliser des choses que nos
parents utilisaient avec nous et qu'on
s'était pourtant juré de ne jamais
utiliser et c'est juste qu'on voit pas
comment faire autrement
puis surtout qu'on a l'impression qu'il
y a que ça qui comprennent il y a que ça
qui marche alors quand j'ai lu tous ces
livres à propos de la communication
bienveillante etc il y a une phrase qui
moi m'a particulièrement percuté c'est
celle que j'avais envie de partager avec
vous elle est issue d'un livre qui
s'appelle la fessée d'Olivier Morel et
cette phrase dit en substance frapper un
homme c'est une agression
frapper un animal c'est de la cruauté
frapper un enfant c'est de l'éducation
quand j'ai lu ça je me suis dit alors
c'est vrai si je vois un mari qui frappe
sa femme pardonnez-moi l'expression et
je vais dire qu'elle connaît si je vois
quelqu'un dans la rue comme ça qui met
un coup de pied à un chien je vais pas
pouvoir m'empêcher d'aller le voir et
lui dire mais ça va pas ou quoi
qu'est-ce qu'il a fait pourquoi vous
faites ça si par contre je suis dans un
magasin il y a un enfant qui est en
train de faire un scandale à sa mère
dans le rayon jouet elle lui en colline
je vais faire ah bah quand même on a
failli attendre
qu'est-ce qui fait que c'est pas pareil
qu'est-ce qui fait que quand elle est
éducative finalement la violence devient
plus ordinaire
et qu'est-ce qui fait que quand c'est un
enfant et ben ouais c'est vrai ça me
gêne moins là il fallait que je
comprenne parce qu'avec la phrase ça
allait pas donc j'ai fait beaucoup de
recherches parce que je me disais si
c'était pas la bonne manière de faire
enfin franchement il y a un moment où
nous aurait dit arrêter tous ces nuls on
va faire autrement et moi à ma
connaissance en tous les cas je n'avais
jamais vu de choses qui disait ça donc
du coup j'ai cherché et je suis tombée
sur une étude qui mettait en corrélation
adolescent comportement à risque et
typologie d'éducation en termes de
violence éducative ordinaire
ils sont pour cela aller dans les
urgences des hôpitaux ils ont regardé
tous les ados qui arrivaient gravité de
l'accident et typologie d'éducation en
termes de violence éducatives ordinaire
est-ce qu'ils ont établi c'est que les
ados qui avaient les accidents les plus
graves étaient ceux qui avaient reçu
l'éducation pour une grosse majorité
très stricte sur ce registre là
ce qu'ils ont essayé de démontrer c'est
qu'en fait on a un cerveau qui
fonctionne d'une certaine manière et qui
fonctionne merveilleusement bien en tous
les cas quand je pose la main sur une
plaque électrique chaude je passe pas
par un circuit long de réflexion tiens
je crois que j'ai posé la main sur une
plaque électrique chaude faudrait
peut-être que je l'enlève parce que
sinon je vais non mais non le temps que
je fasse le tout je me suis déjà brûlé
au troisième degré il y a un espèce de
petit raccourci là qui fait que je
soulève ma main sans passer par ce
circuit long de réflexion
et des petits raccourcis comme ça j'en
ai plein à chaque fois que je me
retrouve en face d'une situation de
danger hop j'ai le petit raccourci qui
analyse est-ce que le danger est
particulièrement gros dans ce cas là je
me prépare à partir en courant est-ce
que le danger est gérable dans ce cas là
je me prépare à la riposte
quand on prend une claque ou une fessée
on n'a pas intérêt à partir en courant
et on n'a pas intérêt à riposter donc on
annule ces deux raccourcis là on les
annule on les annule on les annule
jusqu'au moment où il s'allume plus
et ce qu'il faut savoir c'est qu'à
l'adolescence il y a une partie du
cerveau qui s'appelle l'amygdale qui est
le siège de la colère de la peur
notamment et qui sous le coup des
hormones sexuelles va tripler de volume
donc la colère va être ouh
exponentialisé et la peur elle elle va
être reculée ce qui veut dire qu'avant
d'avoir peur vrai en avoir pour un
moment
alors nos ados de toute façon vont se
mettre dans des situations à risque mais
ils ont normalement les petits
raccourcis qui sont là pour pouvoir à
leur survie sauf que quand ces
raccourcis là ont été mis en position
OFF trop longtemps trop souvent il
s'allume plus et là mon gamin il part
dans le mur et il va vraiment
quand j'ai appris ça mes enfants sont
rentrés à la maison
Corentin l'aîné avait 8 ans Timothée 6
et je leur ai dit plus jamais je lèverai
la main sur vous mais alors purée j'ai
besoin de votre aide
parce que alors je vous jure que quand
j'ai la colère qui monte comme ça mais
je pourrais vous prendre et vous coller
au mur c'est comme une espèce de tigre
comme ça qui monte et qui a qu'une seule
envie c'est de faire mal en face alors
quand je vous dirai j'ai le tigre qui
monte mais vous ne rajoutez rien vous
faites le canard vous montez dans vos
chambres je m'occupe du Tigre et on se
retrouve après
alors si jamais peut-être vous avez
envie d'utiliser ça sachez qu'il est une
petite subtile chose à savoir c'est que
quand on veut utiliser ça il vaut mieux
l'expliquer vos enfants avant que ça
arrive
je vous dis ça parce que j'ai une amie
qui était à table avec ses fils le soir
vous savez c'est le genre de journée ou
faut pas nous chercher
et là donc c'est fini on commençait à
spinailler et un moment donné elle a
senti que ça montait et elle leur a dit
oh j'ai le tigre qui monte
la sa grande de 50 il la regarde comme
ça qui lui fait ça te gratte
tout cuit un minimum d'explication avant
était quand même nécessaire mais le fait
d'avoir mis en place cette histoire du
tigre néanmoins ça a permis de faire en
sorte que mon petit dernier Jérémy c'est
un petit bonhomme qui sait pas ce que
c'est qu'une claque ou une fessée parce
que juste il en a jamais eu et je
n'aurais jamais pensé que ce soit
possible d'éduquer un enfant sans
utiliser ça alors ouais c'est possible
mais par contre il y a plusieurs choses
à savoir parce que c'est vrai que on
peut pas partir à la guerre juste Paris
de bonnes intentions ça envoie du lourd
quand même en face nos enfants alors
pour le coup première chose à savoir
c'est que notre ennemi numéro 1 à nous
les adultes c'est notre propre colère
que c'est important de mettre nos
enfants en sécurité quand la colère elle
monte vraiment histoire du tigre
la deuxième chose à savoir c'est que
notre propre colère à nous elle monte
très très vite vous voulez que je vous
dise pourquoi parce qu'en fait nous on
nous a appris depuis petit que cette
émotion de colère elle n'avait pas le
droit de siéger on ne veut pas la voir
depuis petit on nous a dit arrêtez
colère monte dans ta chambre on nous a
mis au coin nous a mis une fessée on
nous a interdit de manger bref on nous a
appris à faire genre je suis pas en
colère alors que c'est déjà le tsunami à
l'intérieur
et là où est le problème c'est qu'en
fait
on a tellement bien appris à faire
semblant que on n'est pas en colère
qu'on sait même plus quand on devient en
colère et là où ça pose un autre
problème c'est que pour nos enfants bah
oui ils ne savent pas qu'on est en train
de monter en colère il faut savoir que
les enfants ont beaucoup de mal à
identifier un visuel d'émotion en face
une fois sur deux il se trompent nous
adultes on arrive à voir quand une
personne est embêtée quand elle est très
embêtée quand elle commence à s'énerver
quand elle est à deux doigts d'exploser
les enfants eux fonctionnent juste en
mode binaire content et pas content
alors quand on sait que eux fonctionnent
avec ça et que nous on fait genre je
suis pas en colère alors que c'est déjà
le cas oui clairement ça va très très
vite déraper par exemple le soir vous
savez quand on leur dit les enfants vos
pyjamas s'il vous plaît
on y croit on espère que ça va bien se
passer et là je te les vois les deux qui
passent devant pas l'ombre d'un pyjama
sur le dos les enfants j'ai dit vos
pyjamas s'il vous plaît vous avez vu on
entend rien on est déjà 4 5 de la colère
sur 10
et voyant qu'ils ne font toujours rien
les enfants j'ai dit vos pyjamas
un adulte est capable de se dire ouille
ouille vite vite dépêche-toi il y a un
problème les enfants ils se disent le
visuel est encore calme et posé
la voix est calmée posée oh c'est bon
j'ai de la marge et ce qu'ils savent pas
c'est que le fait pour nous d'avoir
essayé de freiner comme ça et ben ça
nous a fait monter à 8 9 sur 10 de la
colère et que si dans trois secondes ils
ont pas fait ce qu'on a demandé mais on
va monter dans les tours mais alors
vraiment j'ai dit bon pyjama avant ça
fait trois fois que je vous le dis trois
fois il y en a marre de répéter et là le
gamin il fait
trois secondes avant elle allait bien ma
mère
trois secondes après elle est au bout de
sa vie moi je ne comprends pas il faut
l'aider alors oui effectivement c'est
important sachant qu'ils ont que ça pour
étudier les émotions d'accord d'être
plus clair plus franc et de leur faire
passer le message de l'urgence de la
situation et donc quand je commence à
être en colère tout de suite je parle
plus ferme plus fort pour être sûr que
le message soit bien passé et éviter
l'effet cocotte-minute qui explose puis
alors il y a une autre chose qui moi m'a
aidé énormément quand j'ai mis en place
toutes ces choses parce que fallait
arriver à handical tigre vous voyez et
alors en l'occurrence il s'agissait de
d'arriver à redescendre quand je sentais
que ça allait monter mais vraiment très
très haut un exemple votre enfant a 6
ans toute ressemblance avec des enfants
ayant existé ce serait purement fortuit
votre enfant a 6 ans il est tard il est
en train de manger pas de manger il a 6
ans tout est dit
maintenant mange et ça fait 15 fois
qu'on lui dit s'il te plaît mange et ça
fait 15 fois qu'il nous répondent ouais
mais je suis
là tout de suite au moment où on sent
que ça monte direct stop maintenant tu
as le choix ou bien tu as encore faim
dans ce cas-là tu restes avec nous et tu
manges le dessert ou bien tu n'as plus
faim et dans ce cas-là tu es bien
fatigué et dans ce cas-là tu vas te
coucher là je viens de lui poser le
choix je lui ai posé les deux
possibilités qu'il a et je lui ai
expliqué que chaque acte sa conséquence
et que c'est à lui de choisir ce qu'il
va advenir
alors imaginons que parce que nous en
général quand on donne un choix comme ça
on a toujours l'impression que l'enfant
il va choisir le bon côté on se dit
quand même c'est mon fils il est
intelligent enfin ça se voit bien que
c'est ça qui est mieux que l'autre et
ben non justement c'est parce que
parfois il a besoin de vérifier si ce
que vous avez dit c'est vraiment ce qui
va se passer bah il va tester alors
imaginons que là mon enfant il choisit
fatigué bon ok alors là on monte pour
les parties allez arriver mieux
d'escalier non en fait c'est super faim
en fait j'ai super super
qu'est-ce que je fais
je repars je vais vers le lit comment je
fais alors il y a une personne atelier
qui me disait ça marche hyper bien le
choix franchement depuis que je fais ça
moi ça marche mais super bien tous les
soirs je pose le choix bon il choisit
toujours fatigué
et arrivé dans la chambre c'est là qu'il
se rend compte qu'en fait il a hyper
faim donc on redescend à table
et là il finit son assiette mais bon
c'est fatiguant
ah bah tu m'étonnes
et qu'est-ce qui comprend l'enfant là en
fait l'enfant il se dit ma mère elle a
une nouvelle lubie
arrivé un certain stade du repas elle me
pose une question à laquelle je réponds
puis on s'en va faire une promenade
digestive
avant que je ne revienne à table pour
finir mon assiette
non quand on pose un choix on pose des
choses qu'on est prêt à tenir
donc les choix du type ou tu t'habilles
ou je pars sans toi quand il a 4 ans
on sait très bien qu'on le fera pas
on rajoute le bling-bling de la clé
histoire d'être bien crédible le plaf
plaf de la porte histoire de bien le
faire flipper là qu'il fasse non
attends-moi non
quand on pose un choix on va au bout de
ce qu'on a dit donc on donne des choses
qu'on est prêt à tenir alors on va pas
se cacher que quand on va quand l'enfant
va réaliser qu'on va aller au bout de ce
qu'on a dit l'ambiance a quelque peu se
détériorer il est possible qu'il pleure
qui se met en colère mais il est
exactement comme nous quand on fait un
choix et qu'on se plante ça vous est
déjà arrivé ça on a la possibilité entre
deux choses on hésite on choisit un truc
et là dites donc tout ce que vous
redoutiez là ça vous tombe sur le nez et
on se dit pourquoi j'ai fait ça mais
pourquoi j'ai choque plus jamais voilà
on est sur la réflexion qu'on souhaite
pour nos enfants
ce qu'ils vont pouvoir faire pour que la
prochaine fois ça se passe différemment
quand on voit son enfant dans cet état
là essayez de vous mettre à sa place pas
en lâchant mais en lui disant à quel
point vous comprenez que c'est pas sympa
c'est vrai quand on fait un choix et
vraiment qu'on se trompe rassurez-le
aussi dites-lui qu'il y aura plein
d'autres fois où il aura des choix et
qui pourra choisir le truc qui lui
correspond vraiment mais vraiment ne
lâchez pas parce que quand on donne un
choix à un enfant on lui apprend des
choses qui vont lui être vraiment utile
pour la vie on lui apprend que dans la
vie on a toujours le choix que chaque
acte a des conséquences et que quoi
qu'il choisisse il va toujours falloir
assumer les conséquences de ses actes
c'est autrement plus didactique qu'une
punition tombée de nulle part puis
surtout ce que ça va lui apprendre c'est
à aiguiser son libre arbitre vous savez
ce libre arbitre dont il aura besoin
pendant toute la traversée de
l'adolescence vous serez plus sur son
épaule pour lui dire qu'est-ce qui est
bien qu'est-ce qui est pas bien à faire
qu'elles vont être les conséquences et
pour sa vie future
en fait c'est ça être parent
c'est donner à nos enfants les moyens
d'être les moyens de grandir les moyens
de s'élever et de devenir des personnes
vraiment pleinement humaine
alors oui ça vaut vraiment la peine
d'apprendre à apprivoiser son tigre et
je vais même vous dire une chose il est
jamais trop tard pour bien faire
maintenant vous savez comment faire il
ne reste plus qu'à
oser et se lancer
[Applaudissements]